foreign
adding a little bit of flavor of
cryptography to this workshop and I hope
it can serve as a good appetite for a
lunch
um okay this is a joint work with timo's
biological area and the Shelf
so at the beginning of this talk I want
to give you a big picture and explain
what motivates us to combining this
cryptographic Primitives to automated
reasoning and formal methods
um so verification now has been widely
used in practice and it can go beyond
self-inches this verification can be
required by many all-site entities one
typical example will be this centralized
software distribution and verification
platforms where the developer will
upload their software to this
centralized Marketplace and this
Marketplace will do the verification and
make sure this software doesn't contain
any manager's code or vulnerability and
then distribute all the software and
after all this verification are finished
and this software Marketplace will
distribute the software to their user
search centralized platforms provide a
solution to a lot of problems such as
this attacking supply chain in supply
chain
however it also risks issues one of the
biggest issues is we put a lot of trust
to this centralized Marketplace
for example first the developer needed
to trust that decentralized the
marketplace respect the privacy of their
software that means the developer should
charge the decentralized the marketplace
will not review the critical component
of their code to any third party
at the same time the user should also
trust this centralized Marketplace
indeed do the verification of interest
and in a proper way
in addition such centralized Marketplace
also raise the issue of Monopoly as they
can promote whatever software they want
to advertise
in in real life such kind of issue is
getting attention and many legal efforts
has been made and we ask ourselves can
we remove such centralized verification
and distribution and replace it using
some alternative
and that's all of this story motivates
us about developing this privacy
preserving form Master teaching and this
two chain actions are protocol that
between the user and the developer so
the user directly interact with
developer the user can verify if the
software or program provided by the
developer satisfying certain expected
property without reviewing what the
program or the software are
and now I want to using an example to
convince you that proving on
satisfiability and their knowledge will
be the first step towards privacy prison
informal methods
so this is a standard way to do some
standard way to do verification so we
have a program and we have some
specification this specification defines
expected behavior of the program and
then we put the programs and the
specification to some standard program
analysis to this too will give us some
formula and the onset viability of the
formula says that any under for any
input the output of the program will be
the factorial of the input and then we
can give send this formula to some
solver if the form formula is indeed
unsatisfiable then the server will
Automotive onset hopefully out for the
sum unsatisfiability certificate
and when the formula is first order
logic formula or propositional logic
formula the certificate will be a
resolution proof however as we said
before when the program becomes private
when the program is private um that
means it's like is encrypted in some
form in some approach and so is the
formula
so the formula also becomes private so
is a resolution proof think about a
resolution proof that is encrypted under
this case how can you still validate
this resolution proof and make sure this
resolution flow is indeed correct how
can you do that and that our question
and there are some generic ways that you
can apply some crypto work Primitives
I.E they are not approved to this
certificate Checker so this Checker can
consume such encrypted resolution proof
um this is a generic way however we do
some experiment I don't found this a
generic implementation of certificate
Checker using a cryptography print teams
is not impractical and doesn't scale at
all
on the other hand our JK onset scales to
the formula it real world formula that's
related to that that's
um for that related to verification
tasks of system driver
what now you may ask why why we can do
that Beyond or why we can't do that like
such scale
um for for such a largest instance uh I
want to give some brief about the
ingredients of our scalability what we
did here is we encode Clause using
polynomial over a finite field and then
reduce checking resolution proof to
checking relations between all these
polynomials
now you may ask why I said then you do
drama about the polynomials over a final
field so incision is this Checker will
do what what's the the certificate
Checker doing is just checking relations
between a bunch of polynomials but why
polynomials why we select polynomial why
we don't stay on the using language of a
set to describe Clauses the reason is
that there are efficient protocol and
their knowledge to check relations
between all these polynomials in finite
fields and they are also well developed
and engineered library for this for the
implementation of such protocol that's
why we finally decided to using
polynomials to represent Clauses and I
will elaborate our approach in the next
few slides in the next slide
uh okay in the next of my talk I will
give you a little bit background
information about their knowledge proof
and the uh maybe we can skip the part
for resolution proof and then explain
our protocol
and finally I'm going to talk about our
a little bit of future
uh so let's give this resolution
um
I want to stop here for a while and ask
ask you a question so the question is
give give given a resolution proof how
can you validate this resolution proof
is indeed is correct how can you check
the validity of the resolution proof so
the resolution proof will be in these
forms where say 4 is a cross is a
resolvent and the zero one means by
applying resolution rule to cross 0 and
class one you got C4 giving you such
kind of resolution proof how can you
check the validity of the proof
[Music]
um
X2 we know this is X2 and then we know
the zero one uh we know we derived X U
by applying resolution route to Cross
zero and plus one giving you proof like
this how do you yeah
yeah okay um
I just use resolution I don't understand
what the question
canceling X1 I'm and then I'm canceling
uh X1 again in the next two and that and
then I just have to cancel XD exactly
actually why this is
um because it's so what we are doing
here is we can like we know this uh X4
quarter X4 is obtained by applying
resolution rule to close there and close
one then we fetch these two Clauses and
as you said we just eliminate the uh the
neutral X1 right sorry X2 X1 right so
we're just applying this restaurant and
then we check okay by applying
resolution to these two Clauses we need
to get X cubed which is let's say four
so we check okay the C4 is obtained in a
valid way so just these two simple steps
and we can repeat this for uh C4 C5
C6 until we meet a contradiction that's
quite easy to check it's quite easy to
check the validity of resolution proof
in the plan text like if we don't talk
about the finite field if we don't talk
about their knowledge we don't have any
concern about privacy then it's quite
easy to achieve and to check the
validity of a resolution proof now when
the resolution proof become private how
can we still do that
and now first I want to give you uh some
functional information about their
knowledgeable that's what we will use in
the next for for achieving checking to
achieve and checking resolution proof in
a privacy prism manner so in the First
Slice of their launch proof I want to
refresh your memory about the Brewer and
the verifier because I know it they have
a different meaning in verification
community and so using this Coke and
Coke or Pepsi example so
in this Pro problem the plural I want to
convince the verifier that I know a way
to tell Pepsi or Coke and verifies that
I don't believe you because they don't
differ at all so how can and then prove
it but but if you show me how to do that
then I will trust you that you really
know such approach
and learn to prove us that
I don't want to show you how I will do
that but I want to prove to you that I
know how to do that so
this there is a very cute solution to
solve this problem if you don't know as
in a probabilistic way if you don't know
I won't leave this as a homework or you
can ask me offline but the point of this
slide is trying to uh to convince you
that there are two parties if they are
knowledge approved and there is approval
that there are approver and verifier
both of them can be my initials and
adversarial in the sense that the
program May treat about his ability to
tell Pepsi and Coke and the verifier May
choice to know what the approach is
now I'm going to introduce their
knowledge proof you know a more
mathematical way so let's say we have a
public circuit
um this circle is known to everyone and
the plural claimed that he knows
assignments that make the circuit output
one
and you want to convince the verifier
that he knows such assignments that make
the circuit out of the one without
revealing any information any
information about what such assignment
is on the other hand verifier wants to
validate and the plural's claim about
her knowledge of these such assignments
and he tried to learn what the verified
transcendant what such assignment is
post proverb and the verifier can be
minutos as I said before the proven
material about his ability he cheat
about his knowledge of such assignments
that make the circuit out of the one and
the verifier is trying to learn what the
such assignment is so that's
um the setting of their knowledge proof
and there are multiple approach to
achieve and other knowledge proof one of
the things we use here is a leverage
this authenticated schemes so authentic
cages game you can think for now you can
think it as encryption schemes or
encryption scheme so authenticated venue
is a cycle text that will hide on the
line value first and then it enable the
verifier to check the relations between
this underlying venue over the
ciphertext so the verifier doesn't know
what underlying value is but only using
the ciphertext the verifier should be
able to check the relations between the
underlying venue and finally also will
prevent approval from cheating about old
online values for example at the
beginning the uh the approver
authenticated or encrypt encrypt a bit
zero and send the ciphertext to the
verifier and then after that after a
while the uh a bit okay let's say it
authenticator base zero and send the
ciphertext to a verifier and after a
while he told uh he tried to convince
the verifier that the cipher text the
underlying value of the ciphertext is
one then the approval the verifier
should be able to detect that the verify
is cheating and not trusted approver so
that's the uh the authenticated schemes
were used as a property we use and
once we have such authenticated schemes
what we can do is we can check we can
have the approver first authenticate or
encrypt all venue the values over all
wires and remember that's the proven
knows what the input of the circuit
should be so the approvers should be
able to compute all the value over the
wires and then
so verify a check if the input and
output of each gate is indeed consistent
over the ciphertext again so the
verifier doesn't know what the
underlying value of a ciphertext so so
the verifier should not be able to know
what the input is and finally the
approval review what's the value of the
output circuit is and if the value is
indeed one the the verifier charts that
approver and didn't know inputs that
make the circuit output the one there's
any questions here
okay so if
uh using the same way we can also verify
the relation between polynomials since
we can check the relations uh like
arithmetrical relations between value we
can also use the same approach to
verifying relations between polynomials
so let's say we have a two private
polynomial what private polynomials by
private polynomials I mean the
coefficient of these polynomials are
secret and encrypted so it's
authenticated in the authentic themes we
mentioned before and to that and the
approval try to convince a very
to prove or try to convince the verifier
that on two point the relations between
polynomials for example here you try to
convince the verifier these two private
polynomials uh equals to each other what
will the approver will do is having the
verifier first select a random menu and
send it this random venue to the
approver then the approver prove these
two polynomials evaluation at this
particular random Point equal to each
other if these two private polynomials
evaluation at this random Point equals
to each other then with large confidence
we know these two polynomials equal to
each other even we don't know what the
polynomial are and when the coefficients
of these polynomials are private
using the same idea we can prove a
little bit more complicated relation
between polynomials such as this product
relation and this relation we call the
gcd relation and this we call the
shifting relations because you just
shift the polynomials for a while and we
use this point these two these relations
are used to later in checking our day
care onset
but if you got a little bit lost here
don't worry I have a takeaway so the
takeaway is uh verify using their
knowledge proof the verifier can verify
relations between private value that
means the value are encrypted or
authenticated so the verify doesn't know
what's the underlying value is he to
verify only knows the cycle text and the
verify can verify the relation between
private value and private polynomials
without learning any information about
what the values themselves the value
themselves so that's a takeaway of the
knowledgeable part
and I hope everyone is still there okay
uh
okay and another takeaway is we have a
we have implemented and well-developed
library for checking relations between
private polynomials that we can leverage
to uh to do a
to design our protocol
it's a problem
so you don't have a like you need to for
example here
for example here you have just a select
a random point and the probabilities
that you the confidence you get about
the equivalence between these
polynomials is the one minus DD is a
degree of these two polynomials
so so it's a one minus D over the f f is
the field the field size you are talking
to polynomials and over so we are
talking about the Financial Field
yeah so it's a for it's a probabilistic
and you can increase it by like for
example selecting two random points have
more rounds if this is doesn't satisfy
it's not that's fine
so now we know they are not approved I
want to concretize a little bit more
about our proving assets liability in
their knowledge setting so in our
setting the prover knows a form
resolution proof and for a formula and
he tried to convince the verifier that
the formula is indeed unsatisfiable
while keep the information about both
the formula and the proof private
and it's a verifier try to validate the
previous name about all of the
unsatisfiability of the formula and both
of them can be my initials in the sense
that the program May cheat about the
onset stability of his input formula for
example if the approval formula is not
unsatisfiable at all the program may use
a fake resolution proof so it's it may
not be like you if you don't have a
sound using some cryptography tools or
tools then it may not be detected since
all the resolution proof is in is
encrypted so if the protocol is not
secured the it's it's possible for
approval to cheat about the onset's
viability of the formula when the
impular formula is not unsatisfiable at
all
at the same time and the verifier tries
to learn the information about the proof
and the formula so we want to keep the
we want to keep the information about
the proof and the formula private
um since as a reminder that because our
ultimate goal is to do
um to verify private software and if
this formula and this formula and the
proof May review a lot of information of
the software as already as a as a
starting point so that's why we want to
keep the formula and the proof private
so as I mentioned before to check if a
resolution proof is required there are
two simple steps one is just fetch the
premise process once checking the
correct check the application of the
resolution rule if the application of
the resolution rule is correct so we
want to implement this two-step in a
privacy preserving manner
so how can we do that we uh we achieve
and Implement these two steps based on
to uh cryptographic premise once they
are not protocol for integer comparison
well it's their knowledge protocol for
checking polynomials relation that I
have explained before so that's a high
level design overview of our work and I
will begin with how can we check uh with
how can we check application of
resolution rule in their knowledge using
polynomial so the high level idea here
is you you think the cross as a set of
neutral if you once you think the closed
asset set of neutral then you can encode
the set of neutrals as a polynomial
where each root each root where the root
of the polynomials is the neutral itself
oh it sounds a little bit confused
as some final field element then you can
represent the set of neutral using a
polynomials where each root of these
polynomials are the encoding of the
neutral
so how can we first encode the neutral
as a final field elements it's
like we use the let's think the final
field element as a bit string so we use
the oh okay what's the K like it's K is
a security parameter so it's not only
for security parameters if you think
like the we mentioned when we're
checking the polynomial of the the
equivalence between polynomials uh K is
2 to the K is the size of finite field
and also the the K is the next bit of
this or the the net speed of these
elements and uh oh yeah and so the case
should be to the K should be greater
than the bit length of the or the the
size of all possible neutral okay
so uh the first bit of this encoding
will be the sign of the neutral and the
rest of it will be the binary
representation of the index of the
neutral so that's uh we had encodings
games from a natural set to final field
element to find out of your elements
once we have this encoding that's the
including scheme we use the in our
implementation but any importing scheme
that satisfy these two properties will
be good enough to be compatible with our
the account that that's but that's the
encoding scheme we have
in our protocol uh so what
once you have encoding schemes from
neutral to finally field elements then
you encode the polynomial the Colossus
using polynomials where as I said each
root of these polynomials as encoding in
the neutral it's encoding of the literal
in the Clauses and for example the if
the Clause is X1 or X2 then
corresponding polynomials will be X plus
2 to the K minus 1 plus 1 times X plus 2
to the K minus 1 plus 2. this 2 to the K
minus 1 is because the first the highest
bit of the encoding is that you want
since X1 and X the sine of X1 and X2 are
positive so the highest weight is set to
one
and so and here we have another example
where one of the neutrals in not X1 so
that's why here is X plus one because
the high speed is set to zero
okay now we have a polynomials for
Clauses to convince the verifier this is
a one step of resolution it's valid one
step of resolution is valid we can the
approver also need to prepare a pivot
polynomial what is Pivot polynomial so
if People's polynomials for pivot
neutral so people who need to resist
literal will eliminate in the resolution
proof we call this pivot neutral and the
pivotal polynomials are nothing but the
wrong degree 1 polynomials where the
constant is the encoding of the period
initial
in this example the pivot polynomials
are expressed due to the K minus one
plus two and X plus two because X2 is X2
and indication of X2 are the pivots
initial
so the pro will prepare all these
polynomials for resolvance input Clauses
and the period Nitro and checking the
relations between all these polynomials
it's a little if you you think if it's a
little bit complicated just uh what I
want to explain it in the language of a
set so this is what happens when we
check in the polynomial but what we
essentially do is checking the relations
between Clauses uh in the language of
that this relation in the language set
so that's what we are all the drama we
are doing here is trying to prove the
relation between a Clauses in language
stats to summarize how we check one step
resolution is using this example we're
having the approver prepare all the
polynomials in coding for input Clauses
resolvance and the pivotal neutral and
then authenticated this polynomials
using the authenticate schemes we
mentioned before and since the
ciphertext or authentic value to the
verifier and the verifier checks the
relations between all these polynomials
and what essentially is the verifier
checking is checking the relations
between Clauses in this language of set
as I highlight here
so that's how can we check uh the uh
what how can we validate one step of
resolution
one when we encoding the Clauses using
polynomial and the reason we're using
polynomials to encode the Clauses is
because once we have that have them in
the knowledge setting this checking can
be implemented and achieved very
efficiently
so that's how we check resolution One
Step resolution but now we also need to
fetch premise Clauses from resolvent or
input Clauses in or Clauses in the input
formula uh this actually uh so so this
action can be done uh in using a
protocol that proposed two years ago
that so you can verify read owning array
operations in your knowledge uh I will
skip the technical details or how can we
verify read the only operation in the
case if you are interested in we can
talk about this of nine but the
takeaways we can indeed fetch or run do
some read only operations to over a
array in their knowledge without
reviewing what the element is and which
index we are accessing so that part of
information is also protected protected
and we also have a check uh we can also
check application of resolution rule
using polynomials encoding of Clauses
and their knowledge
now we have a both of them let's say
what's the performance in project I have
been talking saying that or they can
also scale to real world instance
um so it turns out that our project code
there are two features that affect the
performance of our protocol uh one is
this with is the maximal number of
natural across in the proof can have the
reason why this width will affect or um
well the why the width of the proof will
affect our JK onset is because if you
think the polynomial will use it to
encoding the Clauses the whis actually
is the degree of the polynomial and that
is a site you can think it as size of
the final so that's why it's the ways of
the point of the width of the proof will
affect our uh they can answer oh so
question the the length of the final
proof is not one of the parameters you
need to to somehow preserve privacy for
because it looks like you're going to go
over the whole proof right so I will
know how long the proof is that's not a
concern yeah it's so we will be revealed
so the lens Remains the number of
residents yeah the number of resolutions
that this this you have to reveal to me
yes you have to review and the weeks you
also have to review but you can you can
do some painting for example there uh
for example there are things in the
proof you have a bunch of Clauses some
crosses made for example contains 10
neutral some Clauses contents and two
natural only two neutrals then you need
to pad your proof to you you need to pad
or closet encoding Clauses to up to the
10 so that to hide the the width of the
to hide the uh the distribution of base
of the neutral
hi yeah I might be making a fool out of
myself but I'm just gonna ask it anyway
so my understanding with these zero
knowledge proofs is that effectively
you're you're proving that the there's a
there's a program that is that executes
correctly and this program is
effectively an unrolled circuit that
that that unrolls in this case up to 8
000. is that correct
so you basically unroll this circuit to
8 000 length and and prove the
correctness of this program that you
executed correctly uh it's not uh it we
are not verifying the correctness of the
pro you mean or the program you mean the
in the program will have the first
picture of the program just for checking
resolution proof the checking itself
would be effectively modeled as a as a
program the checking the the Checker
itself is effectively a kind of a
program that is that is on that is that
is executing and updating its own State
and eventually you know and arrives at
the arrow at the empty close which is
what you're looking for and now you're
happy the problem problem is that for
zero knowledge proofs if I understand
correctly what you do is that you unroll
this state all the way to the rent okay
yeah yeah not there that's good so yeah
um so this gets unrolled all the way to
the end and and you effectively have 8
000 steps that now this this the zero
knowledge proof is is very is
effectively verifying with these narx
and Z case narcs and ZK Starks we didn't
quite say which one it was but I'm just
gonna assume one of them so it it it it
uh it does this kind of stuff and my
question is like because there needs to
be a question here is that what is like
how does this work with the 8000 so
because 8 000 is nothing basically we're
gonna have millions here uh yeah I'm
going to show more like more this is
like a uh well I won't say it would take
less than one minute to check this proof
oh okay I know it's quite small in the
standard Community but I'm going to show
what's a larger instance here
yeah okay that's the verification task
we oh sorry yeah just one more thing
like I understand this will convincingly
prove that you're refuting some CNF
formula so how do I know like but there
has to be some connection to like I mean
you could have cooked up whatever right
not x and x and then pad with junk and
it's like how how do I know that you're
refuting something that I'm interested
in does the question make sense you you
accidentally asked a question about the
future work so that's
since you
that you are like the approval and are
not dealing with some random random
formulas is that we can give any uh
onset formula so there is a gap between
the program of interest and the formula
you are in the verify rainy is uh trying
to check the onset stability so such you
need to prove the refinement relations
between this formula at the formula that
is encrypted and the formula the program
that is encrypted so this refinement
relation verification checking will also
be should be also implemented in their
knowledge and that's one thing we are
now working on yeah thank you thank you
for asking this question yeah and let's
uh okay let's get back to the evaluation
and that's the result we got uh so the
online is a venue for how if you know
the how the um model checking is how can
how do we deal with the loop and as you
see that so they can set can check uh
the onset the formula onset liability or
formula for verifying system drivers
let's say for system driver application
within five minutes and that's uh for
this system driver verification formula
for formula for of system and Driver
verification and we also Benchmark oh we
also Benchmark a even larger instances
here so and the nimeter here is a when
the width is about 1000 and the lens is
about 600k then the machine we used to
be we use in I post in the first slides
will run out of memory so the process
got killed but uh we recently have a
work so to use a Computing cluster to
even improve this result so that instead
of one machine we can have a multiple
matching and run this resolution
checking and then checking the
consistency between different components
so that's the result should be further
improved
okay and let me conclude this part of my
talk so privacy preserving for methods
is really in demand and also we can
encoding uh the proof and the Clause is
using polynomials so they can be checked
very efficiently in a privacy preserving
manner finally uh what was the account
set is a practical and can verify this
real world instance and uh now I want to
talk a little bit about the future
um recall oh okay
an obviously okay recall that the title
of this Workshop is about satisfiability
but what I have been talking about is
unsaturated now let's get back to the
topic of this auction so
um so we are we actually have a
considered uh like a set solve Set uh
satisfied but solving uh in privacy
preserving setting as a first place and
the second is when there are two parties
they have their input formula and they
want they want to check the conjunction
of their input formula it's satisfiable
or not however both of their constraints
can be private things like for example
if you think these constraints are
personal schedule then that will be
reviewed a lot of information and
privacy so we want to protect the
information protect the privacy of the
their input formula and we have this
preliminary results that
using multi-party computation which is a
protocol in cryptography to do to
achieve such that solving privacy
preserving in privacy preserving setting
what we do did here there is we're using
a matrix to encode the formula uh here
is like we have minus one but
essentially we are doing is using our
binary Matrix to encode the formula so
all these operations happens in dpll can
be reduced the tuning us again over this
Matrix which is expensive very expensive
but it can so why we want to have an
English again is to hide the to hide the
index access so that so that we can
protect the input formulas privacy and
we also Implement some heuristics uh one
is DRS which are great aggressively to
assign the neutral that will satisfy
most Clauses once rent is just a
selected render undecided the natural
and the
um and then and assign it a random venue
and also it's a way to the random it's
still render on selection but to give
some weight about each decision uh both
of why we want where we Implement these
three curious It's because
um they are we they are quite friendly
in this privacy prison setting that's
why we have these three uh heuristic as
uh this preliminary result however I
want to show you this result which is
very depressing so we ignore this
parameter here or I will show I want to
say all influence we have here is a
small to medium size instance that's
instance and as you see it takes about
thousands of thousands seconds to solve
this small to median instance when we
won't enhance the privacy and yeah you
may think this picture comes from
decades ago but no it happened last year
but and we also Benchmark using this we
use we also use case data to solve this
Benchmark and this since that needs
hundreds of thousands seconds to solve
he said only needs
um 0.02 seconds so it's depressing but I
want to remind you that that solver this
case that they involves decades yes of
engineering and Theory but this will be
the is the first work towards the uh
self-solving privacy preserving setting
and we want to ask ourselves can we find
a better heuristics when it comes to
privacy preserving setting or the better
data structure to represent the formula
that's the question we really want to
answer and to improve
um
to improve the self-solving even when it
comes when even when we want more
privacy so thank you and if you have any
questions please don't hesitate to
contact me and this repo has all code we
have and I'm also on job market if you
are interested in hiring please contact
yeah
so a question in all of your settings
like the formula is part of the secret
right yes which you don't want to review
I just want to point out one secondly
crazy application that you might already
be solving which is like a commercial
proof vlogging okay which I might
actually be a problem like why would you
not expect C Plex and gurobi to want to
implement proof logging in their MIP
solvers well we all know what instance
they're solving but the secret sources
of course they're amazing
um
you know they're amazing heuristics and
why they saw their their
the instance is so fast and of course
the state would release the proof log
then you could reverse engineer and you
know I can build my solver to be equally
efficient okay so you could argue that
maybe to be commercially viable you
would like like I know what instance
you're solving I can verify your proof
but I have no idea what the proof is
am I making sense yeah yeah I think so
and that's sort of you seem you sort of
have a baby version of that problem
solved already
but because if like if I if I knew
if I know the formula then I could
probably verify your original fetch
operations maybe and then I just know
that apparently you have some proof and
the zero knowledge proof is going
through so apparently you did decide on
sat right so it seems that you sold my
formula honestly
but I have no idea what your solver did
so C fixing will be would be very happy
yeah thank you I think that's very
motivating
yeah to answer one quick question my day
and
very basic question I it looks like
you're implementing this uh these Surah
knowledge so is there an implementation
of just checking satisfiability I've
given this
so original
uh the implementation so given a formula
and there is an assignment uh I want to
convince
I think if you want to check our sex
liability that means you have a
assignment that makes the phone I know
that I have an assignment but I have to
tell you that this is an assignment then
you can use the standards like they are
knowledge approved yeah is that an
implementation that people have done
that or no not interesting I think there
are also well I like there are even more
like optimization for that but I don't
I'm not aware of like any particular
ending implementation like especially
for formula assignments but for any
since that is empty company I think many
problems
I mean there's a whole range of work I
think on like efficient implementations
of probabilistically checkable proofs
for instance which would be exactly this
right where you're optimizing like the
length of the proof and you're
optimizing like although the formula has
a billion variables or a gazillion
variables you only want to read like you
know at most 1000 bits from this proofs
proof and then you still want to know
with 99 probability that indeed you had
a satisfying assignment and some of
these things actually go into like some
of these new cryptocurrencies and stuff
so like one of our former esteemed
colleagues in the proof complexity
Community
is now like getting filthy rich on doing
this kind of things instead I think it's
like very very cool work where you take
like the the highly non-trivial
theoretical PCP constructions and then
really squeeze out the juice and you get
it to run on practice so this is
system
I guess it's a dumb question but you
said the verifier could can be malicious
so what if the verifier just refuses to
to believe that the that the polynomials
were equal uh uh okay uh here with the
manicious model for the verifier is a
verified tries to none it's not the the
goal the goal I understand you you want
to
verify to be malicious in in one way but
but the verifier
does have to to say well uh uh you your
proof was convinced you should verify
can't you see I I I deny that I that
that
that it worked yeah what I showed sorry
what I show here is interactive version
that's the verified directly interact
with approver but we can also like in
this work is also compatible with uh um
some there are energy proof of backend
that is now interactive so the proverb
can generate a proof and publish or
generate their non-deproof for outside
the ability of the formula and publish
it so so make it the public so even the
better when the verify want to deny this
uh to deny the outside a bit of the
formula since the proof is public the
there are some like you may use some
other technique like for example voting
six games so to a bunch of verifiers
that if most of them are are not
malicious and you have you can come to
the right result
foreign
like clarifying the model is it should
we think of the verifier like this is
honest but curious kind of
um
so I think it's not a uh honest and
curious like it's in in a setting where
the verifier may need to to verify
neither to follow some protocol for you
can see it yeah okay the answer is
passionate yes but I but uh I want to
emphasize here is someone you say
Securus and uh Curious honest about
curious you usually need to verify need
to do several steps that violates the
protocol and it's usually happens in
multi-party computation where this
two-party want to come on to computer
function over their inputs and the the
goal of this verifier or the other party
that violated the protocol is trying to
trying to mess up the output of the
function that's uh but I don't say but
yeah you can think like they are curious
honest about curious so the only the
goal of them is to learn information
about the input formula yeah
yeah okay so uh let's conclude uh thanks
a lot again
[Applause]
we're going to have lunch break now and
we'll meet at 2 pm for knowledge
compilation